spencer caitlyn jenner announced her run
for the governor of california
how did brody feel about that how do you
feel about that
you know i immediately texted him to no
response
so i you know i i tried i
you know i obviously would vote for
caitlyn jenner just to have a connection
into the governor's office even though
we're not you know caitlyn and i have
had our issues things i've said about
parenting in the past but still i have a
better relationship with her than i do
with any
potential candidates so i obviously
am in support of it i was a little
thrown off that none of the kardashians
are backing
her so you know i do love kris jenner so
that threw me off
you know but you know sorry chris i
think
i would like to have connection to the
the powerful office of
governor so you know yeah here's my
answer brody didn't respond
i thought we were getting more serious
about trying to get pregnant is that
dangerous for a baby for you to be so
stressed out every day
how does season two of the hill's new
beginnings
compare to season one for me way more
intense everything was just more intense
but just the pandemic energy
the people the crew
the settings i mean everyone
obviously was just heightened it was the
energy was very
the relaunch of the reboot had a more
like but still like it had some intense
moments but it wasn't just
always the frequency felt like like it
was wild and maybe that was our
experience
interacting like with a lot of the cat i
mean sometimes it was more fun
and more intense i felt like i could be
a part of it because season one
i was breastfeeding and i wasn't really
at a lot of the group events and i was
home and that was like my main priority
and
this one i definitely was like there and
adriana and i had some really fun like
turn up moments and how we did
we saw the tick tocks we loved them and
then there was just yeah a lot more
intense
real moments as well speaking of real we
do see in the trailer that you guys talk
about
whether or not you are really trying for
baby number two
are you actively trying are you ready is
gunner ready for a little brother a
little sister potentially
benner's really ready i think that's
part of why it's like a little
or has been a little hard for me because
he's always like where's my baby where's
my baby and i'm like mommy's trying
really hard
you know so trying too hard yeah we are
actively
trying since december so hopefully
sooner than later
my fingers are crossed for you guys i
know it can be a journey so
yeah i love that you're being so open
about it